I think the the real political divide in
the modern West certainly in America but
in the modern West more broadly is
this divide between what I call the
great reset and the great Uprising right
the great Uprising is the response to
the great reset a view that says you
have to dissolve the boundaries between
the private sector and the public sector
between nations between the online world
and the offline world so everybody can
work men and women yeah that's a
different dissolution of boundaries
actually between the genders it's all
about dissolving boundaries
so that the leaders of Institutions may
work together towards the common
Collective good that's the vision of the
great reset and it's different from the
side I'm on the if I had to pick between
the two the great Uprising which says
hell no to that Vision we the citizens
of nations in America the citizen of
this nation as a citizen of this nation
say we decide in a self-governing
Democratic Republic how we sort out our
political differences that's really the
divide the managerial class versus the
everyday citizen